on last night's show we did a sketch
featuring one of our sponsors subway
subway is one of the sponsors on the
show and we did a little sketch with
them okay and the sketch involved an
actor in our audience okay we do that
from time to time we've been known for
doing that for years we Twitter
actors in our audience and then they
perform a part in and among the real
studio audience
yeah well this audience was just on camp
they were just we put him on Cameron
they were fantastic right well during
the bit we did last night there was an
audience member in the background who
would not stop hamming it up for the
camera just would not stop it was going
on the whole time just here's a brief
look at what he was up to Subway makes
them you eat them it's that easy
they make them I eat them I understand
now I understand sandwiches
and that sandwich literacy
[Music]
now you see everybody else who was in
the audience and you could see about
what least 25 other people behind him
they all managed to get through the
sketch and even enjoy it but not that
guy that guy just couldn't do it
okay now I'm sure I know what he was
thinking he was thinking I'm gonna do
this there's nothing Conan and his gang
can do about it and then because he
tapes the show a little bit early as
much as half an hour before it airs play
along no because we tape it a little bit
early he was thinking I can now go home
and watch myself on TV all the time and
being awesome well guess what we had a
little surprise for that guy we found
him so distracting
we had our graphics Department used
their latest anti douche technology this
technology has just been released to us
we just came up with it yeah and it
completely erased him from the show this
is 100% true take a look at the version
that actually aired last night and
really pay attention it's that easy
they make them I understand now I
understand sandwiches
and that sandwich literacy
[Music]
they digitally took the red curtain in
the background and put it over that guy
yeah frame by frame
okay and it costs us a lot of money to
do but man wasn't worth it cuz I know I
know that guy went home and got his
friends about it's like check this out
[Applause]
you